as the pandemic evolves we humans are
not the only creatures facing a new
reality zoos and aquariums across the
world who have gone quiet
human visitors are no longer allowed the
animals though still need to be fed and
cared for and since ticket sales stopped
so has the flow of money to pay the
bills zoos are under intense pressure to
adapt or go the way of the dodo
Tom Hayes explores some of their
survival tactics it's a trip to the zoo
like never before and the excitement's
building I want to see the Lions the
Bison the grizzly bears I love that
would be baby longlegs born just over a
week ago at the Toronto Zoo normally she
would be a big attraction here with 1.2
million visitors every year but this
year is different
Payton Jackson and the rest of the
family in the car to take in the Toronto
Zoo drive-thru
[Music]
they came forward with the plan that
allows people to stay in their vehicles
staged in the parking lot
literally drive through our front
entrance and use a combination of our
walking paths as well as our zoo mobile
route to get a behind-the-scenes unique
experience
[Music]
that unique experience will generate
revenue but not even close to the 51
million dollar annual operating cost
it's not really happening
attractions across the country are
facing a real challenge to keep their
creatures fed and doors open it's
honestly it's like comparable to a death
a death of a dream a death of you know a
passion cherrybrook zoo and st. John's
new brunswick closed for good because of
kovat 19 the Vancouver Aquarium in
Stanley Park is losing 3 million dollars
a month the hope is to open sometime in
June with limited tickets but planning
is also underway for a worst-case
scenario given that we put aside money
to make sure that we can rehome the
animals if we need to close we need to
make sure that we're not you know just
leaving those animals without support
and finding new homes for them it's
going to be a top priority for us then
that also costs money what would be most
critical for them to feel comfortable
coming back to us for a safe experience
the Calgary Zoo has reopened to a
limited amount of visitors but its star
attractions the giant pandas are on
their way home the zoo can't get enough
bamboo to feed the Bears during the
pandemic so they will head back to China
with no public viewings before they
leave just outside Montreal it takes
about 30 pounds of meat every day to
feed the Tigers at Granby Zoo half a
million dollars a year to feed all 1500
animals with no opening date in sight
the money's running out we couldn't
expect to be able to run on the two
month three months maybe basis and after
that it will be really tough we'll
probably need the bank help and people's
like the foundation to be helping us to
government-level also some programs the
food budget is also an issue here at the
Toronto Zoo it costs over a million
dollars a year to feed the animals that
million dollars usually comes from
parking revenue from a parking lot
that normally doesn't look like this
with no paying guests for the past eight
weeks many attractions have reached out
online it's a different way to tour the
zoo but the hope is that the drive-thru
concept will still allow for social
distancing and allow families and escape
from the covert lockdown just the
ability to get them out of the house and
to do something as a family and
obviously to support the zoo and all the
employees that have been working
throughout to take care of the animals
we're happy to come out and see what
it's all about today Jackson and Payton
give the zoo drive-through a thumbs up
finally getting to enjoy the animals and
it sounds like the feeling was mutual I
think they were happy to see us